what a week it has been in the united
states and
uh i'm going to try to put together
some overarching thoughts about what
we've seen in the country
over the last week and by what we've
seen i i of course am talking about
what is really a predictable and logical
culmination
of the most depraved and disgusting
presidential term that we have ever seen
i mean donald trump inciting a riotous
insurrection in washington dc uh when he
simply could not admit that he simply
lost to joe biden he wishes he could
have won but he didn't and
unable to do that it led to what we saw
last week and causing that to splinter
the republican party
part of which has immediately abandoned
donald trump far too late to actually
deserve any rehabilitation of their
reputation
um but it is merely a move for
self-preservation
part of which uh that republican party
continues to defend donald trump
while the country fights a global
hundred-year pandemic that has been
completely mishandled
and seems unable to get the mass
vaccination program growing so it going
so that's
that's like the big picture and we have
to be able to say something overarching
about what's going on here
and there are a few lessons in the midst
of the chaos but the most
important thing we can do
is to not understate the importance of
this moment as an inflection point
in the path of the united states of
america
and it's impossible to include
everything that's happened
and i know that many of us are are still
sort of struggling to figure out
all of the answers about what happened
and there are so many details different
people finding more interesting or less
interesting
and focusing on but there will be
continued time for that
i think understanding the big picture
here and the importance of this moment
is the best thing that we can do
and it really goes back to 2016 when we
had tons of republicans most of the
right
saying we like trump much of the right
saying well we don't love trump but we
still think he's way better than hillary
and we also had too many of our fellow
leftists
saying trump wouldn't be that bad or he
might even be
sort of like hillary i don't like either
so i won't vote
they're both corporate shills i don't
see any practical difference between the
two
or let's mix it up by putting in trump
it'll be wacky and it'll get us a real
progressive in 2020.
oh the supreme court's not that
important you remember that stuff
those people were all wrong the ones on
the right were obviously wrong
and the ones on the left were obviously
wrong as well now we don't need
apologies
let's just recognize that they were
wrong
the people on the left who were sounding
the alarm
as we saw trump's authoritarian
tendencies
and and immediate we saw them before and
immediately after getting elected
and some of us were called hyperbolic
and over exaggerated
if anything we understated the risk
every
worst instinct of donald trump's has
become
the nightmare scenario and it culminated
last week and it might not even
be the culmination we'll talk about what
the next week and a half is going to
look like and it looks like it will be
utterly insane
i'll tell you what donald trump has
planned there will be more armed riots i
am sure of it
how successful they are remains to be
seen so this
is all to say let's not sell short the
importance of this moment and there are
two ways that this moment could go
big picture one way is very
straightforward
we all decide that this can never happen
again
and that putting politics aside putting
aside your view of like
tax rates putting aside your view of
business regulation
we decide as a country that what
happened last week is an existential
threat to the united
states we recognize that joe biden will
be president
and that we have to go back to drawing a
line in the sand and saying
all of this from the last four years is
over the line of what is acceptable
period
no matter what your view is on taxation
right
and part of this is i i have to say
not tolerating trumpian insanity it's
not
valid politics it's not valid activism
it's not valid participation in the
political system and it has to be
stopped
now you will hear some say if we don't
tolerate tolerate other points of view
then we are as bad as them
um and that that's ridiculous
some are saying this in terms of trump's
permanent twitter ban which i'm going to
talk about later
it's just other opinions and we must be
tolerant
it's the wrong perspective we tolerate
other opinions yes
an armed insurrection of the capital is
not an opinion it's a criminal
travesty it's anti-american it's
anti-democratic
and when you tolerate everything
eventually
the truly intolerant come to power and
destroy society and the very tolerance
you want doesn't exist anymore
and it is you who who is being silenced
okay
this is where principles stop being
valuable in the abstract yes we are a
nation of tolerance
we tolerate other types of people we
tolerate other religions or no religion
whatsoever we tolerate ideology
we tolerate political ideas and descent
and adversarial media yes all of it we
tolerate all of it but
you have to know how far that goes and
what we're seeing
doesn't have to be tolerated and it
shouldn't be understand that if we
tolerate what we've seen over the last
week
there will simply be more and more of it
until
they are in power and are completely
intolerant
toleration doesn't fix it toleration
doesn't
change minds so one option is that as i
said we as a country come together
against what we're seeing we recognize
that the country ceases to be a country
if this scoff law criminality and
revisionist history
and unhinged authoritarianism is
tolerated and that's going to be tough
for some people
i'm with you if you are a moderate
republican if you're in the vein of like
john mccain for example
it's going to be really tough to say wow
i'm a republican
but that was bad and it's it's
unmitigated there's no ifs ands or buts
it was a mistake we lost and now
we have to eliminate this malignancy and
joe biden is going to be president for a
while
democrats will have the house and senate
for a while that's tough to accept
even if you've been disgusted by trump
as a republican
so to those folks yes we need to be
tolerant and accept them
but we do not need to tolerate what led
to the armed mob last week
there's no planet on which that can be
tolerated we really are on a precipice
does this escalate even supposedly with
more planned
planned riotous mobs in the next 10 days
or do we actually come together and i
mean the left
and the center and the sane right and
law enforcement
and our sane elected officials the ones
that are left and say this can never
happen again
and to stop that and uh uh
it's going to take years to fix but do
we start today or do we let them get
away with any aspect of it
we on the legal we must take swift legal
action against trump
and the terrorists and every state and
local republican member who supported
this
that's the best way to put a stop to
this movement there have to be
consequences
and one of the things i'm i'm sadly
seeing
our reactions from some of these right
wingers saying you left it david
it sounds like you hate the country why
not leave or whatever
no no no no i'm an immigrant to this
country and i'm incredibly grateful to
this country
i want more people to get what i've
gotten
from this country and trump is the
opposite of that
if we allow what happened last week to
grow
and to fester we go the opposite of what
the united states should be and
i know that this has been said so many
times it's not patriotic to to just
stand by a politician just because
they're president
we talked about this when the right
tried to say you're not patriotic if you
don't support george w
bush's war in iraq no no no that war was
bad for the country and so it's
patriotic to stand by what's best for
the country and i've warned against
deifying politicians by both the left
and the right
uh it is patriotic to stand up for
what's best for the country
even if it conflicts with your
partisanship so do not
understate the importance of this moment
and we're going to talk more about that
as we get closer and closer to the
inauguration of joe biden as president